Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Hi, welcome along to today's podcast episode, which is a little bit different than
usual. It is my first on tour. There might be a little bit of jiggly camera work here and there, and I'm sorry. Please do persevere with it. I will find somewhere to prop it up when I can, but you are coming on tour with me to Galway and we are going to go and do a keynote speech. And there's lots and lots of steps involved with getting me from my front door to the stage and then back again. So I hope you enjoyed today's episode and yeah, I hope it all works, but you'll be there with me every step of the way and we can do this together. All right. Take care. See you soon. I am just waiting for my Uber.
Okay. So I know the plan originally was to film all of this on my iPhone, but I realised that seeing as most of the listeners to this podcast episode do listen on MP3, that if I didn't do some sort of main feed with me talking you through the processes, that it might not make a whole heap of sense. But that said, this is going to be best viewed on YouTube. So even if you've downloaded this as an MP3 on Spotify or Apple, Amazon, you know, maybe come and take a little look over at YouTube. Dr. Marianne Trent. Whilst you're there, why not subscribe, like, fling a few comments around. So, yeah, I wanted to make this as
useful a process and interesting a process as possible for those watching on YouTube and for those listening on your phones or however you do indeed listen to your MP3 content. Right, so let me give you a little bit of background into why I was going to Galway and how it came about. So in I think it was probably June or July, I was first contacted to ask if I might be available and up for coming to an in-person conference in Galway. I was contacted by a lovely, lovely person called Hannah Flynn. And she was so kind. She was organizing the conference for the Irish Psychological Society and she'd been just so accommodating and welcoming and friendly and when I met her in person she was equally as lovely. I wish we'd got a selfie Hannah that
would have been nice that would have been fun. So we finally got the venue sealed as being Galway University, which had been some of the hold up. That was finalised just towards the end of July. And then I went on holiday sort of immediately. And then it was kind of promotion central from the Irish Psychological Society. And then it happened in September. So that's a little bit of timeline and context into how this came about. And I was asked in my capacity as a qualified psychologist to do an hour's talk, not necessarily specifically from a clinical psychology discipline, because the conference happens every year, also, I learned on the day. And it's for people in the first 10 years of their graduation from a psychology degree.
And what we know about psychology degrees is that often, they will take people in very different directions, sometimes in the direction of becoming a qualified psychologist, and sometimes in, you know, very different directions that can be equally as fulfilling for people. So yeah, there's many, many steps involved in getting me from my home to Galway, and to the university and back. But I thought it was quite a fun little road trip idea for a podcast so I do hope you find this useful and I'll do my best to guide you through it. So with no further ado yeah let's get started let's get on the road shall we. So I decided I was going to get an Uber to the airport because the parking didn't seem to be worthwhile and I thought
it would be a lot less faff to just be able to you know order and go so that's what I did but the thing I hadn't quite expected although I should have done because the same thing happened when I went to Birmingham with a friend for dinner one night is that it was a hot day and the driver clearly didn't want to switch the air con on and so instead had the windows open and my hair was just going wild which wasn't so bad when I was about to take a flight but when I was about to go out for dinner with a friend and I had preened and curled my hair it was less than ideal so yeah have a look at that for yourselves I hope you can hear me okay it's really noisy here um so the journey in the uber went really smoothly um and randomly um the taxi driver who's originally from Ghana had lived in Malwa for 17 years. I couldn't make that up, so he's giving me all of his top tips.
We're doing some work here at Birmingham Airport, so it is quite noisy. So, yeah, I hope you can hear me okay. Annoyingly, Ryanair won't let me check in until 1.20, which is a bit annoying. Which now means I am in a cafe with some cake and a herbal tea and you know me I do love my herbal tea. I realised I think I said they won't let me check until 1.20 but I didn't say what time it is now so the time now is 5 to 12 so yeah I'm gonna walk around there again in just over an hour and just sit here with a magazine and pass the time. So I absolutely did sit there for a little while and then I thought you know what Ryanair,
it is a self bag drop and so I'm gonna chance my arm again, I'm gonna meander on over there but the same lady saw me again and said oh dear um she's already told me not to come through and so then a few minutes later as I stood there waiting I saw her go off what looked like a lunch break so I joined the queue and the new person um on Ryanair didn't ask where I was going um just to check my passport and so then I went to the self bag drop, dropped my bag and went through to security so yeah always pushing the boundaries a little bit but you know I had places I wanted to be, I had my laptop with me and so I wanted to be you know a little bit further ahead not in that very noisy pre-security airport departures section so there I was found myself getting through security pretty effortlessly although I did forget to take my laptop out the bag and then I was free to explore the duty free. I managed not to buy anything but
yeah it's always something about that environment of walking through, smelling all the perfume, seeing all the Toblerone bars that you definitely don't need. I do like travelling and yeah I found travelling independently to be pretty good too. I will admit that I wasn't really looking forward to the time in the airport lounge waiting for my flight. That is because I'd taken a flight from Birmingham Airport over the summer and our flight had then been delayed for three hours. And what I observed was that if you hadn't got there early enough there was nowhere to sit and it wasn't particularly enjoyable now of course I did have young children with me for that trip which always adds an element of pressure and for this one I was traveling solo but I decided if I was going to be delayed I would rather be delayed where I could work from my laptop and where I had
power in case I needed to charge my phone and also where I had food so I did treat myself to an airport lounge it cost me 38 pounds and had I been able to spend three hours in there that would have been marvellous but I was able to get myself some food which was a little bit uninspiring I had a little glass of wine and I had a little clotted cream scone then I was able to sit and do some work I planned some social media wine and I had a little clotted cream scone. Then I was able to sit and do some work. I planned some social media content and I did some email scheduling ahead for my membership and so it felt like a good use of time and I was also able to keep an eye on the departures board. Would I recommend using a lounge and would I use one in future? So it was my first time in a lounge and would I use one in future so it was my first time in a lounge and I would say if I was
traveling again by myself I would definitely do that again because it just it was so quiet and so peaceful and it meant I had a guaranteed place to sit where there wasn't any chaos going on and yeah whilst it would have been cheaper to go to Wetherspoons I feel like it would have been more stressful and in terms of doing myself a kindness ahead of my trip and my presentation the next day I really felt that would be yeah the most compassionate thing I could do for myself because I was worried about all of these steps you know there were a lot of steps from taking me to my front door and then back the other side and so it just felt like a little bit of a reward to kind of yeah give me a little pat on the back and say it's all right
Marianne it's okay this is this is kind of one step further in your journey so yeah that is I would I would do it on a case-by-case basis i probably wouldn't pay for for my children to join me um but i would definitely go if i was going by myself again right i booked the airport and it said it was closest to where ryan i buy an air fly um or by gate one and now my flight's been announced as gate 57 so I have a bit of a dash to get there okay I'm in the queue to board I'll admit I'm a little bit hot and bothered I have to say that it all went pretty smoothly for Ryanair from the point that I dropped my bag. Everything happened as it needed to happen. I was able to board the plane, find my seat,
settle down. It was very hot on board initially because it was a super warm weekend. If you're listening to this in the UK, it was the weekend in September where the temperatures were above 30 degrees and it was so warm everyone was completely sweltering. The flight itself was good it was it was nice to be able to spend a little bit of time doing a little bit of puzzling. I'm a big fan of like that's life and take a break puzzles and so I did a little bit of that and read a bit of my book. I looked out the window it was really nice to kind of watch the scenery go by, watch the clouds go by and then to see as Ireland appeared and got gradually greener and greener so it was a very different experience than traveling with children so I did rather enjoy that yeah and then we got off the plane and it was a really tiny airport
so I'd flown into Knock airport and it was just really small and really cute and yeah it all went seamlessly once I got in the airport there was like this lovely sunny photo wall that said welcome to knock and so I thought it's the perfect place for a selfie it would be rude not to right here I am at knock airport I've just picked up the keys for my car hire hire car hire car uh let's go and see if I can find it then was trying to find which one the car rental desk was so I've not hired a car since I was in New Zealand in 2003 so it was a little bit rusty um about how to do that um but yeah it went it went well it went smoothly it's a little bit of a queue because by the time I found the right desk everybody else had already beaten me to it.
But yeah, it was good. And I then got to learn which car I was having. Well, I've managed to find my car. It is a Dacia Duster. I've never driven one of those before. Have been in one. Almost bought one when I was pregnant with my oldest child. But my husband test drove it.
Said it was awful. So let's see how it goes that's it luggage stowed managed to somehow work out how to open the boot now I've got to drive and find myself on the way to the Airbnb in Galway there was this error that seemed to be on the dashboard for the car for the whole trip I just don't think I noticed it to begin with and it said inflate tyres and in it and I think that meant there was some sort of sensor on the car which had sort of inflated the tyres but letting you know that they needed some attention so I don't know it seemed to be fine. The only thing I struggled with was I've got an automatic handbrake and I did
keep forgetting to take it off but all went well and then as I was driving oh I was so delighted when I turned on the radio are you even in Ireland if when you get there on the radio they're not playing Westlife on the radio they're not playing west life so it was a little over an hour and a half driving through um yeah pretty main roads i would say violent mainly motorways um but yeah they were fairly well behaved considering it was um rush hour it was around 5 p.m by the time i landed so yeah it was it was pretty good and um and as i was driving along I was listening to the iRadio and I said what is this? They kept referring to the ploughing championships and I'd never heard of that before and they were giving away tickets to the ploughing championships and I couldn't quite work out why the people that won them sounded so excited. That's something I asked the guide,
who you'll hear a little bit more about later in the video, about what it was. Why were people so excited about this ploughing championship? And I was informed that it's a really big deal. And people, it's like a festival. People, there'll be bands there, there'll be activities, there'll be things to buy and things to do. It sounds a bit like Glastonbury and apparently people don't always watch the ploughing so it started as the ploughing and yeah it's it's it's apparently really really fun so I was almost sad that I wasn't going to be there for a ploughing weekend which I think was the weekend after I was there but I learned a little bit there about Irish culture and yeah I feel a little bit less naive in terms of at least where ploughing championships come in
so I managed to find myself there and was delighted to see a lovely lovely cat who lived at the B&B welcoming me in. You are so cute. Now I had booked on Airbnb and it looked all right you know the downstairs areas look wonderful. I knew I was going to be having my own bathroom but it wasn't en suite and it looked okay but what I wasn't prepared for was that it just blew me away. The lady who was hosting me was wonderfully warm, welcoming, so friendly, so chatty, such an interesting, interesting life that she'd had. And her home was immaculate. She could have been an interior designer and it was just all completely lovely. So once I was settled
in I took a stroll into the local area of where I was staying and went and got myself some dinner and on the way I saw a beautifully decorated apothecary clinic and I just thought it was a really lovely looking building. It would have made a really nice therapeutic space if you were going to be setting up a private practice as well. I found myself in the most beautiful street. I wish I'd taken a photo of it. I walked down it the next day in the daylight hours and it looked completely different because the street was open it had beautiful beautiful lights all above it and because it was a beautiful warm summer's evening everybody was outside there was tables in the road and it just looked like the buzziest most fun
street but everywhere was kind of pricey for me just eating dinner by myself when I just wanted to eat and then a little bit further along still under the beautiful string light I found a cafe called the secret garden I went in there and I had a lovely curry and they treated me really nicely and then I treated myself to a little pudding as well I think it was a homemade rhubarb crumble it was good and the next morning my lovely Airbnb hostess did me proud with a really beautiful breakfast so I'd taken my running gear with me and I was planning on going for a run but when I was chatting to her the day before she said that she just really loves the company of people and chatting and learning about their stories so I
decided that it would be really better for me and better for her if I was to sit down and have breakfast and continue to chat with her rather than the benefit I would get from going for a run by myself so that is what I do. Okay so I am ready I have breakfasted I have got myself into my outfit I've eaten my breakfast in a tea towel so that it doesn't mess up my outfit I had a slight difficulty with the necklace I want to wear so it's quite special to me because it was given to me by my first supervisor when I was a trainee and she's no longer with us so I wanted to wear it to bring something of her to the event but unfortunately when I got it out of the pouch I'd kept it in it somehow broke in itself into several different pieces so I've sort of had to hodgepodge it together to put that bit behind here but it is supposed to so I've sort of had to hodgepodge it together to put
that bit behind here but it is supposed to come down to sort of stomach level so I'll have to do some sort of more permanent fix when I go home but for today that's it I've just got a jacket I'm gonna wear I've got to change my shoes because they're quite high I'm not gonna manage to wear those um all day um so I'll change those just before I go to the venue. Right, I'll see you there. Take care. Okay, so I'm hoping that I am here at the university. Oh, my windscreen wipers seem to be on. I don't know how to turn them off because the key is not in the ignition.
I almost hit myself in the face with the boot as it came up. I managed to avert that. It's quite a vicious little boot, this Dacia Duster. I wasn't expecting that. I hope I'm quite near the university building where I'm going to be going in. Yeah, don't know if I'm parked in the right place. Sort of hope that I am. Parking, I won't lie makes me a
bit anxious no one likes the idea of being clamped but it did say like white line spaces are not enforceable at weekends but none of the signs seem to say that so hopefully be okay I'm only here for sort of about two hours by the time it's all done and dusted so here we go um don't know how much I'll be able to talk to you in the event if at all um but I might see you well I will see you on the other side so me and my broken necklace my laptop I've got to change my shoes because I'm not going to manage to walk around in the very high heels that I'm wearing um even for two whole hours uh my lovely Airbnb host has given me a little bag to put my trainers in when I'm not wearing them um she's so lovely so I'll see you soon so I was in the event I was in the queue with the delegates waiting to go in and I was like oh I'm a little bit nervous and then yeah I went to the
front of the queue and I said oh I'm Marianne I'm here to do here to do the keynote speech and everyone sort of turned around and looked at me and yeah then I was chatting to Hannah it was lovely to meet Hannah in person and then I was chatting to Hannah. It was lovely to meet Hannah in person. And then I was chatting to some delegates. I was having a look at the poster conference and I went and changed my shoes. And then I decided I was going to go into the auditorium early and talk to some of the people that were there. I was chatting to three people at various different stages of their journey and it was really refreshing actually because I'd sort of written the speech with aspiring psychologists in mind being at different stages of their career and yet someone was an assistant psychologist someone's about to start a master's you know on the Monday after the event and so yeah it felt like I pitched it appropriately and it was just really nice to speak with them and I as I was chatting um to one of them well another one turned around and went oh I believe you might be our keynote and I was like yeah I am ah it felt a bit strange but
yeah nice it nice and you know the speech went well well and people sort of ran out after me to go and speak to me so it felt like a really nice thing to have done and yeah I talked through my outfit on stage and why it was significant so the skirt I was wearing I bought when I learned that I was going to be an assistant psychologist at St Andrews Healthcare because I believed I needed assistant psychologist outfits. The je Healthcare because I believed I needed assistant psychologist outfits. The jewellery I was wearing was something I'd had made when I was travelling in Morocco and the necklace as I've explained to you was very significant because of who gave it to me and it just felt really important that I'd be able to bring the different stages of myself
and have them be represented on stage with me. So that felt really lovely. And it meant that I didn't need to go out shopping and buy something new, which was also better for the purse strings too. Well, that's it. I'm all done. Galway's treating us to a little bit of rain, but it went well. So I'll speak to you from the car.
Here I am again, back in my little car office. So I think it went well. People sort of stopped me on the way out saying how much they'd enjoyed it. A few people laughed at some of the stuff I said, which is good. Not all the way through, that would be weird. But yeah, the reception was warm. I managed to weave in seven different practitioner, psychologists, disciplines into my speech in a way that hopefully was engaging and made sense. Because the conference is for people in the first 10 years post-graduation, which sounds like a really, really nice organisation and a really supportive way of helping advance people to the next stages of their career and supporting and inspiring them wherever they are. So, yeah, it was absolute pleasure to be there, to see the lovely uni, to be back in, you know, lecture theatre as well.
So if you watched me on stage hope it was useful um and in terms of how I felt um so I think I was a bit nervous about the parking which I mentioned earlier um and just making sure I was going to be there in the right time in the right building because I'd never even been to Galway before let alone sort of Galway Uni let alone the specific building that I was going to be in so you know it's always okay to let yourself be a bit hesitant about the things you've not done before but obviously give yourself plenty of time to make sure you can jump through the hoops in the right order and still give yourself time to to decompress and hopefully be a bit less sweaty because it has been very warm um yeah it is raining a bit now so um i didn't bring an umbrella so i've got a walking tour of galway booked in
later today and hopefully drizzled out by then and before then I've got to get a spot of lunch as well so I'll catch up with you very soon I am back in my parking space I'm gonna go and get changed and then I'm gonna head out into Galway and get some lunch oh I thought I'd tell you about my hire car as well so it's got like a manual handbrake that i'm clearly not used to um because i keep forgetting to take my handbrake off my handbrake on my car at home is automatic and so far nobody has honked me despite me not being that speedy getting away from the lights because i have my handbrake on so yes it's very nice clearly the drivers in Ireland are a little bit more laid back than I'm used to which is really
really nice so following that I went in and I got myself changed and sorted and then I had a cup of tea and a slice of cake and lots and lots of lovely chat with my lovely Airbnb host which was just marvellous and then following that I took a stroll into beautiful Galway and I took some video of the lovely street I'd been in the evening before but it looked so different because of course the road was open there was traffic you know driving up and down it and it was raining and so it almost made me a bit sad but I wasn't able to have the opportunity from the night before when there was lovely music playing and people were just out living their best lives having drinks in the venues in the street and chatting and there was just so much of a warm inviting atmosphere and yeah it just looked so different in the daytime and then as I was walking into Galway
I saw a blackboard sign that said there was a traditional session happening later that afternoon and I thought to myself oh well if it if it so happens I'm still in town by that time then I'm gonna I'm gonna go in and I'm gonna have a glass of wine and I'm gonna enjoy listening to a traditional authentic Irish session. I love being by water and as I was walking into Galway city centre it was really nice to see the river. I think it's the River Corrib and walking along the bridge where people have done love locks. It just felt like a wonderfully calm, safe city to be in. And the city was breathing a sigh of relief because it had been warm for the days preceding that and so it was definitely comfortable to wear a light denim jacket and everybody was kind of pleased it wasn't quite
so hot as it had been in the days before. So for me the city felt a little bit like Brighton but safer and with more sort of music playing which there is often music playing in Brighton but it just felt well it felt very Irish and it was really really lovely and I just really enjoyed soaking it all up I probably looked a little bit weird going around filming but it was just really nice so I'm going to shush for a minute and let you listen to some of that music and see some of the sites and this is where it really does pay to to come over to YouTube and watch it here so that you can just with the red door features in one of the videos for Ed Sheeran's songs for Galway Girl and that is the restaurant that I ended up eating in it's called Ard Beer and it's just really
really funky and what I hadn't realized was how popular it is so I ended up standing in a queue because I couldn't really find anywhere that I wanted to eat and the lunch menu on the outside looked fabulous and as it turned out when I got in there they gave me the brunch menu I don't know if I was perhaps too early for the lunch menu but I think it was about 12 o'clock by the time I got there it was 12 30 by the time I got there which is lunchtime but the staff were really friendly to me and I ordered myself a really tasty poached egg and ham hock brunch with a kombucha. And it was really, really nice. And then I had some free time to explore Galway before meeting up with my walking tour. So, yeah, checking out the Galway girl statue, finding myself taking a little selfie in front of the Irish lottery and some Irish souvenirs.
So I'm just about to go on my walking tour. I am at the Spanish Arch meeting by the museum in Galway. It's sort of raining a little bit still. I'm wearing a coat and I can see everyone in England currently is melting. So I'm quite enjoying wearing my coat I'll see you soon I had booked myself onto an Airbnb experience it was called Galway's legendary walking tour and it was by a chap called Neil really affordable it was only 13 pounds and it was an hour and a half what I was really hoping was that I could also book on to a food tour which was starting just after that but by the time I had emailed her to ask about start and finish dates she'd sold her last place so maybe next time I visit Galway I'll be able to do that but the tour was really lovely it was
quite intimate it was quite unique because there was only three of us on there because Ireland were playing in the rugby so I think most people were probably inside avoiding the drizzle in the pub watching that but it was really nice to learn some more about the city to understand why the green post boxes are green and why they look so familiar to those of us that have grown up in the UK, to learn about the history of the city and those who've lived there before. I also really liked all of the street art in Galway as well and just being able to yeah to see the people of Galway and there's a very famous corner where apparently Ed Sheeran used to busk because I think his grandparents used to live in Galway so he spent a lot of time there
and so it just yeah it's just lovely to watch the city to experience it and yeah just to enjoy it's free time it was great to be able to see the way that they had intertwined the old city. So the old city walls that now sit within one of the shopping centres there as well. And then before too long, it was time to say goodbye to Neil and to the lovely married couple who were visiting from America. Oh, let me say goodbye to you from that walking tour but I'll be back along in a moment. So in Ireland apparently you don't say goodbye you say safe home which was really nice to be able to capture on camera as well. I didn't get any photos of them when we were on the tour so it's nice to be able to say that and I did check with them that they
were happy for me to include them within this vlog and they were and in fact there will be details of Neil's legendary walking tour in the show notes if you do want to book that for your next trip to Galway and then a little bit of free time to be able to primarily buy my children gifts which was which was the agreement they had struck for me to be able to go off because they were like we'll miss you I was like I'll buy you presents they're like okay yay and so yeah I stumbled across a lovely vending machine selling sweets with the plan being that I would give a packet to each of my children but I also sort of gave them to the family as well and me and my husband devoured them I'm not sure the kids got much out of them at all but they were so delicious so if you see any hay candy vending machines or
any shops selling hay candy dig in Now in Ireland they have a large supermarket chain called Dunn's and I'd already been to a Dunn's in Northampton because randomly there was one in there, I don't know why, but that was the only Dunn's I'd ever been to in the UK and I strolled through there and I brought myself a little Tippex mouse and some pens because they were things I needed for the business but also I was a little bit peckish so I did pick up some chocolate and all my days it was completely delicious so yeah apparently Dunn's chocolate is is is really worth really worth um indulging in so yeah if you're in Ireland get yourself into Dunn's and buy some mini Dunn's chocolate bars because they were utterly delicious and just at the end
of the tour Neil and I were chatting about just about lockdown what it'd been like and that my family and I had really got into ice cream during the lockdown as a way of just having family time and a little bit of a family tradition and he said oh if you like ice cream you've got to go to this one place where they sell brown bread ice cream and I was like that does not sound good brown bread ice cream and he said trust me trust me get yourself over there um and try it out so it's called Murphy's so I did exactly that I used my phone to guide myself there um and the lady there said I could film as well and then I sat and ate my delicious ice cream and I think I had two scoops I had brown bread and I
think I had a peanutty one as well and they were both completely delicious in fact I might go as far as to say it was the most delicious ice cream I've eaten it was scrumdiddlyumptious as they say and I just sort of sat there on a little little seat in there and chatted to some of the staff and they said it had been so hot in the few days before that because they have so much air con but they have the door open to encourage trade and they're always out with little trays of kind of tasters for people that the condensation had just been dripping off the ceiling because it was so warm so they were delighted that it was cooler um and it was yeah if you are in Ireland I would say absolutely check
out not only um Neil's walking tour I wish I don't get paid to say you that it was just it was just lovely um also check out Murphy's and then it was time to start my journey in reverse walking back through Galway towards my B&B um and yeah just enjoying the late afternoon sunshine um and I went past the pub and I was right on time um and then I noticed on the pub sign that the sign had been changed there was no session that day so that was a little bit disappointing but I did then go and have a drink out in the sunshine watching the world go by from a bar that I'd seen the day before so not quite the same as a traditional Irish session but still enjoyable nonetheless then I went back to my Airbnb I got
changed into something snuggly and had a cup of tea with my Airbnb host and then she'd said she would love to make me dinner which was just so kind and so that is what she did and we ate together and it was just the loveliest evening so tasty so friendly and so welcoming and then of course her lovely cat Tommy was equally as welcoming let me just spend a little bit of time with Tommy now too. You're a lovely cat. Yes, lovely. He's very happy with you. We're very happy with you, Tommy. Oh, he loves that.
Oh, he's so cute. You're the loveliest thing, aren't you? Yes, you are. Yes, you're beautiful loveliest thing aren't you yes you are yes you're beautiful you're beautiful I'm just having a cup of tea with the lovely Frances before bed because I've got an early start tomorrow and she's insistent that I must have some cake so I'm gonna have some cake and then go to bed. So I've had my cake and I've eaten it and Francis has been telling me all about people who've stayed here before and apparently in this very bed Colin Farrell stayed. He was making a film in the Isle of Arran. I've not watched the film
but he stayed here for a few weeks and took care of Tommy the cat good fact and on that note with the time at 9 p.m I am going to go to bed um it's been what feels like quite a long day it's been lots and lots of activity. See how many steps there's been. 15,500 steps. It's been a great day in Galway. And I've got to get up really early. So I think I'm getting up at half past four. So yeah, I will love you and leave you.
See you soon. So you can see as the video progresses that I get gradually tireder and tireder and tireder and then getting up super early the morning I flew home didn't help but I'd also had a bit of a restless night the night before because it was still quite warm and I was worried about missing my flight and so I woke up at one in the morning and then was awake for a few hours and the night before that my first night in Galway I just sort of kept thinking about the next day and about processing everything I'd experienced that day and so I just didn't sleep terrifically well then either and so I just felt like more and more depleted the time that went on so let's touch base with me now as I am up very
early morning it is kind of early it's just gone 4 45 in the morning I am all packed up I'm ready to go I'm in the car I've had to wake up my lovely host Frances because she told me she'd be very cross if I didn't which didn't feel very nice but yeah I'm hoping I can find my way back to Shannon Airport which is a different airport than I flew out of because it wasn't possible to fly into Knock and out of Knock or into Shannon and out of Shannon at times that were human and even though this doesn't feel like human it is much better than the other options that I had looked at so I will see you hopefully when I've got some fuel a bit worried about finding fuel that might be open at this time um and how I open the fuel filler cap but I've had
a little bit of a youtube research I think I know um and yeah hopefully I can get to the airport get a hire car back get myself sorted pass all the Ryanair checks and be away. So as I was driving, it was so foggy in patches. So I had to go nice and slowly and steady. And I did pass a few petrol stations, but they weren't that close to the airport. So I sort of ignored those because I thought I don't want to fill up the tank and then have it not be on full when I get back there. And I assumed to be one pretty close to the junction for the airport, but there was not. And so I found myself on the site of the airport still not having filled up.
So I then had to turn around and go back into Shannon Town and then use my trusty sat nav to look for the closest petrol station that was open. So yeah, I did manage to do that, but it made it a little bit more fraught than it probably needed to be. So the people near Shannon airport, you may want to open a petrol station on the motorway near Shannon Airport because many people will be hiring cars that need to be returned on full so you're missing a trick so in the end I think I ended up shopping at the Circle K in Shannon so thank you very much to you good people for being open at 5 30 in the morning on a Sunday morning or whatever time it was it was very early by the time I got there but get there I did I'm looking a little disheveled as I was in the airport so I am all checked in at Shannon Airport which is a lovely airport I have to say and you can carry your own
water and drinks through with no problems which is good now I'm just gonna wait for my flight the lovely Frances packed me off with breakfast this morning she made it for me last night popped it in the fridge uh so i've had strawberries and raspberries and a bottle of water which is just so lovely so i was there i got checked in had my breakfast um and then it was just you know time to wait so the flight coming back was similarly as effortless as the one going out but it was quieter which meant that I had three whole seats to myself which is always a bit of a treat but it was so short haul that there wasn't any time for kind of laying flat and napping which was something I had enjoyed when I was traveling around the world in 2003.
My friend and I had both managed on a long haul flight to get I think it was like a row of four or five seats to ourselves so essentially had a flatbed experience for backpacker prices which was just wonderful. Yeah it wasn't quite a flatbed experience on Ryanair but it was very speedy and actually I have to say that um even when I was flying back into Birmingham the baggage carousel situation was amazing for both flights my baggage was pretty much there as soon as I'd been and had a trip to the ladies and then I was at the carousel and it was there whereas in contrast when I was flying back from Birmingham in the summer we'd had to wait about an hour for all of our bags to appear so I was kind of
anticipating that was going to be the case it was a very pleasant surprise so very well done to the luggage crew at both Knock and Birmingham airports. I am now back in the drop off zone at Birmingham airport and I'm waiting for my Uber. Shouldn't be too long. I am really quite tired now and feel quite dishevelled. And I'm looking forward to getting home. Thank you so much for following my journey from door to door. I'll do a quick one when i get home and then that will be all hope you found it useful i hope you found it inspiring and helpful for kind of thinking about when you have new things to do that might feel challenging that might feel a bit overwhelming you've got this thank you very much and I'll look forward to catching up with you again soon so tired just
back from Marianne Galway is going to be closing this episode but I did think that I would just say a few thank yous so thank you very much to the Irish Psychological Society for inviting me to be their keynote speaker. It was lovely. I loved it. And I had so many interesting, inspiring chats with people both at the event and since you've contacted me on social. So yeah, thank you for curating a really wonderful, supportive, friendly group of people and wishing you very well and wishing you all the best in what you do next and how you support the future generations of psychologists too also want to thank um my airbnb host and her son for being so welcoming sorting everything out for me and of course tommy the cat um and i want to thank you guys for listening um and yeah if anyone listening is interested in booking me for keynote um speeches in future or would like me to come and do some sort of behind the scenes vlog of a conference
or an event let me know and we'll see what we can do. I've had fun with this. I'd also like to thank my podcast editor who kind of inspired this little vlog thing because he asked me whether I ever take any b-roll footage of actually what I'm up to in the day and I was like no, I don't. It's not very exciting. So this time I thought, well, this is more exciting. It's been a labour of love, this podcast video has taken me ages. So I thought, well, this is much more exciting than what I usually get up to. And it's nice to have company when you're on tour. So I thought I'd bring you with me. So yeah, hope that you've put up with my
camera work that you can cope with me getting tired and tired as things progress I am now filming this a good few weeks after the event I've recovered my tiredness but it is now at the end of a working week I've had a busy day and I'm back from swimming with the kids I've just finished dinner so even getting the a-roll snippets ready for this video have just taken me a little while so you may notice I've changed outfits a few times but I really wanted to bring this to you so let's let Marianne who's now back in her house fresh from Galway just utterly shattered let's let her sign off but thank you very much for watching that is it I am home and I had such an interesting chat with my uber driver on the way home about all things football and then the fact that he'd actually been a law graduate originally and then got a 2-2 and we kind of worked out together actually he's a bit traumatized by that and we kind of encouraged him
to move through that and to think about the steps involved with perhaps studying for a master's and then beginning to get back into the law career so by the time I got out the uber he'd come up with a bit we'd come up with a bit of a plan how many steps he's going to spend a few minutes before his next job um looking at maybe some masters and you know maybe thinking about sending some emails off to get that started so yeah love love my job love the chats that I end up having with people and he's like thank you so much Marianne this has been really really good like and it's kind of empowering stuff that potentially begins to change his life and the life of his family as well although he sounds like he's doing a great job anyway but you know sometimes when we feel
like we need to and want to live up to our full potential and the things that you're originally you know heading in that direction for so it matters it really matters um and we're never too never too old to do what we want to do so i think he said he's 30 34 i think he said and i was was like, you know, time is young. You know, just do what you want to do. Yeah. So thank you very much for following my journey. My children and my husband are out.
I think one of them might be at the grandparents and the other one's at football. So I'm going to enjoy a little bit of peace and quiet. I wish I could have a nap. I'm quite tired. But yeah, I will see you for the next episode of the podcast which will be coming to you from 6am on Monday thank you so much for being part of my world if you're watching on YouTube please do subscribe like let me know what you found useful about this episode and I'll look forward to seeing you very soon. Take care. then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified
it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with dr marianne my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist
I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.